let's turn now to the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they
arrive in the next half hour we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
guardian columnist zoe williams and the
director of communications at the
institute of economic affairs annabelle
denham so
let's have a look what's on some of
those
front pages and looking ahead to her
majesty's funeral the express proclaims
farewell our glorious queen
the male calls it our last farewell
the metro says now carry her home
and the telegraph pays tribute to
what it calls a life of selfless service
the star describes the country as a
kingdom
united
charles gives thanks referring to that
statement from
the new king tonight
that's the times
the eye references the global scale of
the occasion
likewise the guardian mentions the
presence
of
those many foreign leaders
and just a reminder that by scanning the
qr code on
the screen now during the program you
can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers
while you are watching
and as i say we're joined by zoe
williams the guardian and annabelle
denim uh thanks both uh annabelle first
of all the telegraph has the new
picture uh released
tonight by buckingham palace and the
headline a life of selfless service
which
i guess just about sums it up yes it
does indeed i mean it's the final
portrait as well of course that will
will ever be taken of the queen i think
you have
that portrait of her beaming uh on the
cover of many newspapers and and almost
a contrast really with the headline a
life of selfless service because
she she did have a life for
self-disservice and she did it often
with a smile on her face and that's what
that's what's really coming out of those
uh front pages
there i believe she's wearing a she's
wearing blue she's wearing a brooch that
was given to her when she was 18
again you know she lived until she was
96 and and for the vast majority of
those years she was our queen so
it's not surprising that that's that's
on the cover of the of the papers that
final portrait
and so i mean the papers have been
remarkable haven't they the last
few days really the the images and the
pictures i mean devoting page after page
to just
very
you know impressive spectacular
photographs yeah i mean it it has been
interesting to watch the newspapers
because there's always
generally speaking papers are trying to
distinguish themselves from one another
so it's really
it's it's very difficult from a news
standpoint when they're all doing the
same message with the same photo and you
did find at the very beginning that
there was a kind of split between the
papers between the ones who are using a
very young photo and the ones who are
using a very current photo obviously the
kind of the regular
kind of rule is that you use the most
recent photo but it was felt that those
young younger photos were so impactful
precisely because they really really
drove home just how long the rain had
been um now i think
that you you're not going to find much
dissent on the front pages
no and the immediate express also
i mean fills its front page with that
same image of
a smiling queen and clearly this is the
image that the the family wanted out
tonight
yes one expect so and i think also
over the last couple of days we've
perhaps seen some newspapers cover other
stories on the front pages whereas it's
not altogether surprising that tomorrow
on the day of her funeral the vast
majority have these single shots of the
queen let's not forget that by tuesday
the news agenda you know news is
relative and by tuesday the news agenda
will in part have moved on of course
there'll be coverage of tomorrow's
funeral this this momentous day that has
been planned for for some time now and
it's going to see
foreign dignitaries and leaders to stand
on london well they've already descended
on london in in huge
numbers it's a day-long event of course
ending with that private service but
much of it will be televised and
expected four billion people are going
to tune in so it's a huge event you can
expect that it will be covered in
tuesday's papers at length but i think
this may be the last time that we see
those full shots the portrait of the
queen on the cover people are going to
be papers are going to be thinking this
is a kind of once or twice in a lifetime
occasion on which people are going to
keep the paper to remember the event by
you know it's like people don't tend to
keep newspapers but they'll probably
most people will keep their newspaper
from the day of the queen's funeral so
it's got to be impactful but at the same
time it has to be you know it has to do
exactly the respectful job it has to do
so i mean
i think i think they've tried a decent
balance and i think you can tell a lot
about the readers from the way they've
done it i mean you can look at the
express and think that's exactly the
cover the express readers will want
i mean there's been so many days when
the the front pages have been
you know
front pages that people might want to to
keep it's been
you know the day after her death was
announced we've got today tomorrow's but
you know
tuesday's papers will be i'm interested
zoe that
the guardian
probably more than most other papers
over the last uh nine or ten days or so
have gone for other story i mean on the
front page the cost of living and and
ukraine yeah
stories which you know have tended to be
on the inside of of
other people i mean that will be about
readership and it will be about
editorial values right so there have
been a load of really important
environmental stories this week and it
would be against the values of the paper
but also you know arguably against the
values of the royal family to prioritize
the
to prioritize this event for 10 days
when you had such kind of momentous news
from pakistan you had such huge news
from the ipcc and none of it good there
is a kind of you know the newspapers
have to make a call when there's a in a
period of national mourning whether
they're going to completely jettison all
other serious content
and some newspapers did make that call
but you know not all newspapers were
ever going to make that call i should
just uh say i'm getting news in my ear
that the queue has
finally closed so
there is no point now in turning up at
the beginning of that queue because the
queue
has uh closed
those in it will
still be able to over the next few hours
be able to um
see the queen lying in state but uh
there's no point now
uh turning up at the beginning of that
queue and i mean it's been astonishing
isn't it
well and also you know we're talking
about how newspapers have been covering
this and repeatedly day after day over
the last nearly two weeks trying to find
new angles new new ways of covering this
this very very big story and i think
that the queue in the middle of the past
week actually did give newspapers a bit
of a a fresh angle a new way of of
approaching it and i don't think that
anybody perhaps expected that the queue
was going to be so long i think it's the
longest queue that has ever been uh in
history at least that we know about um
so it's enabled newspapers to to
change up their coverage a little bit
and and really
put forward the you know this outpouring
of grief that's come from the public
just how much the queen meant to the
public you know i think it's i think
it's wonderful that the british people
have been willing to stand for hours
some people with perhaps disabilities
some people uh who are separate
generations optionarians standing in
that queue for overnight to to go and go
and see the queen as she
yeah there we are that's on the website
the queue to attend the lying in state
is at final capacity and now closed new
entrance please do not attempt to join
the cube but it's been astonishing the
cue capital letters had its own twitter
feed um
it was on instagram people were
filming themselves in the queue some
people did it twice i
read
today
so what do you
put it down oh look clearly people are
going for different reasons what what do
you think
there has been
actually it's interesting there has been
some already some sociological research
on it by these university of sussex
researchers which
it we've found that it's it's a slightly
more complicated picture than a than a
kind of cure of mourning people join
things because they
enjoy the sensation of being part of
something and that's that's been huge so
they're you know while everybody there
was certainly a monarchist while it was
predominantly a conservative crowd it
was 52 percent conservative
it was not overwhelmingly so um
it wasn't it had a really good age split
it was 59 female but generally speaking
and right up until the age when you
really wouldn't want to sit on a
pavement you had a really good
distribution across the generations um
and a lot of people
you know there was a kind of splice
between
wanting to feel part of something and
wanting to kind of give voice to some
amorphous gratitude um and that
that did foster a really good atmosphere
right because if you're if people are
going for those reasons it was kind of
communitarian and also
um grateful
vibe then that's good that's going to be
that's not going to be a a bad cue
that's not going to be like an airport
queue
no
there was a real sense of camaraderie as
well yes there was
took her nine hours or so
but she said she said i'm not really a
monarchist you said but i just wanted to
be there because it was a moment in
history and that's exactly that's
exactly it that's exactly what the
researchers found it wasn't particularly
fervent um you know
monica something just um forgive me for
a moment let's go to matthew thompson
who i think is at the
back of the queue i think matthew give
what's the so it's closed what's the
scene down there
no longer the back of the queue because
the queue is no more finally the queue
has closed after five days of queuing
we've been here throughout there were
still quite a lot of people left in the
queue by the time they tried to shut it
off to be fair they did try and get as
many people through as possible but it
was clear
about by about an hour to ago that there
just wasn't going to be enough time to
get everybody through we know that the
queue takes about eight hours to get
from where we are now basically by
london bridge all the way to westminster
we know also that the queen has to be
cleared out of westminster hall so that
the funeral can take place tomorrow by
half past six so the simple mathematics
meant that they had to close the queue
around an eye and they've done so the
queue was finally closed lots of very
disappointed people saw a few people
quite emotional about it one person not
that emotional but a little bit
disappointed as lauren agreed to speak
to us very quickly just your thoughts on
missing out by a whisker yeah literally
if we we went the wrong way as well so
if we didn't go the wrong way we would
have probably made it in time
so yeah absolutely gutted we went across
the bridge rather than straight over
so it's a it's a shame that how long
were you waiting to get to this point
i think around two hours okay so you
hadn't been waiting sort of six hours it
would have been slightly more gold
so what are you going to go and do now
join yourself
go and have a coffee and sit down
rest your weary legs and yeah we just
take a walk around take the views
have you come far out of london
from lucent okay yes
a while but not you know you haven't
come from lands
commiserations thank you are you gonna
stick around for the funeral tomorrow
perhaps you can't see any of that or i'm
not sure i'd like to but i'm not sure
we'll see we might we've talked about it
i'm not sure it depends how many wines
you're driving
exactly
i'll let you get on thank you so much
so there you have it finally the queue
is at an end i feel like i've spent most
of my life here over the last week
but it is clearly not for the many
people still in it many thousands of
people actually still in it because
they're gonna be waiting overnight the
queue itself will stop letting people in
around six o'clock in the morning but it
is closed as of now to any new entrance
okay matthew thank you very much indeed
i saw it said um
yesterday the nation is divided into
those in the queue
those watching people
in the queue and now you've got those
who missed the queue so the queue story
goes on but what what do you think it
says about
the country or the monarchy
can we
really people we're trying to draw a
kind of patriotic stroke exceptionalist
case that it just meant that we
particularly liked cueing
um and you know there is
that certainly the kind of british
cliche that we like cueing anyway a kind
of abnormal cue is likely to likely to
be abnormally attractive to us um i
think it i think it probably is exactly
the same reason your daughter joined it
you know it is a it's a moment to mark
and you if you want to kind of tell the
grandchildren where you were that's the
place to tell them where you were
yeah and you have stories to tell as
well people have taken to social media
um and friends i know who've been in the
queue will tell you about the roller
coaster of emotions that they had
starting off and feeling really excited
an hour in there tucking into the snacks
two hours and they're starting to wonder
if they've made a huge uh error um but
determined to you know continue and wait
and then of course when you actually
enter into westminster hall the phones
go away the social media is completely
forgotten and you're there for this
moment of
solemnity of calm um
and you know it's a really pr i
understand from those who've been there
really sort of profound
experience um but perhaps not one that
they were expecting when they were
actually in the queue and we saw images
today of
um
several world leaders um who didn't
cue or join the queue as such clearly
but they did go and pay their respects
the guardian front page world leaders
descend as nation prepares for grandest
of farewells and i it's difficult to
think of another person who would have
been able to gather this
it's unbelievable i mean leaders to
their funeral you wouldn't be able to
list the world leaders who are going it
would be much much quicker to list the
kind of handful who weren't going and
it's i really do feel for the met
particularly and for secure anybody
involved in security of any kind because
it's such a high jeopardy event you know
even having biden in the same room as
macron is like a you know
a
complete kind of
it's really out of the ordinary what a
challenge this poses
and these world leaders and dignities
many of them have actually gone far
beyond protocol so it's possible that
this was at the extent of this was
unexpected so there would have been a
huge amount of planning and preparation
that went into it but were they really
aware that it would be on on this scale
i don't know yeah
and
we're looking at uh
president biden there now he's one of
the few leaders i think who is allowed
to motorcade the rest are
going to the funeral
well effectively by bus well i think
i've seen loads of motorcades no well i
think maybe today or maybe it was just
biden going either another
um
but you see here you've got the beast
arriving at the palace
that's not the president but it's his
car and you've got um the buses arriving
and uh apparently tomorrow a lot of them
are going um
to have to go together by bus which
could be an interesting study in
um
diplomacy if nothing else but it'd be
interesting to see because but it is i
mean it's a it's a diplomatic nightmare
the whole thing isn't it if you've got
to see people on buses you've got to
then seek them at the funeral who do you
sit next to who and these these issues
of protocol have probably never come up
you know between
you know which between norway and sweden
who's meant to walk first i bet you
that's never come up um but you know i'm
sure everybody will be gracious about it
because it's
they wouldn't have arrived if they
didn't think it wasn't about them and
it's a serious point for
um king charles because
a lot of conversation about the queen's
soft power
well he had a reception here um behind
us here tonight
and what an opportunity for the new king
i'm sure he knows most of them anyway
he's a 73 old man and he's been around
for a long time but important
yes i mean he's a very very long
apprenticeship hasn't he um preparation
for the role you're right this isn't
just saying farewell to the queen this
is also an introduction to
uh the new king um many of whom as you
say charles may have met uh in the past
but not not in this role he's going to
be trying to establish what sort of
relationship he will have with them in
the future and try to ensure there's
some continuity of that soft power that
the that the queen had the queen had to
such an extent that we have these 500
dignitaries and leaders descending on
london for for her funeral no it's you
know it's quite a an extraordinary event
and one suspects not one that will be
repeated certainly in our lifetimes if
ever again
no
um
and
we've got you know i'm trying to still
trying to think of anybody who would
mandela i suppose possibly
churchill possibly would have attracted
this kind of um
uh number of world leaders but um
it's extraordinary thing um the the
people that she is gathering here uh
there's the eye world's farewell
to
elizabeth
ii